hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about two topics that have made quite an
impact in recent biology those are
genomics and proteomics so what do these
words mean well
genomics refers to the studying of it
whole genomes entire genomes that is
complete sets of DNA in a Cell so this
tells us about all of the DNA all of the
genetic information stored in a species
and this can be very very complex for
example in humans there are 3.2 million
base pairs that make up our genetic
information proteomics is similar it is
also studying a large amount of content
but rather than studying sets of DNA
proteomics Studies sets of protein
sequences
so this refers to those amino acid
sequences that make up the proteins and
of course the proteins in our cells are
what are the functional aspects of the
cells proteins are involved and
practically every cellular process for
example in humans there are between 20
and 25,000 proteins and at this point
approximately 1/4 of these proteins are
still unstudied that is they've been
found within the cell
but nobody really knows yet what they do
now genomics and proteomics what makes
these things possible mainly two things
perhaps most importantly is DNA
sequencing DNA sequencing is up and
coming technology it's getting better
and faster all the time at piecing
together not just all of the base pairs
and a given genome but the order in
which those base pairs are put the order
in which they exist now once you know
the order of the nucleotides you can
then determine for the protein coding
sequences that is for the nucleotide
sequences that actually code for protein
you can determine the amino acid
sequence that is coded for by those
nucleotide sequences and of course that
is made possible by the fact that all
organisms share a universal genetic code
if you are interested in learning more
about the universal genetic code how it
works how it helps us to go from a known
base pair sequence or nucleotide
sequence to a known amino acid sequence
then see my video on the universal
genetic code but now let's move on to
something else
why are genomics and proteomics
important why do we care about studying
whole genomes and studying large sets of
protein well a few different reasons in
terms of human medicine it allows for
faster identification of new drug
targets we mentioned earlier the
approximately 25,000 proteins that human
cells are capable of making many of
these proteins are essential in various
cellular processes and when something
goes wrong with those processes disease
results and so by understanding the
proteins that are present in our cells
and which proteins may need to be
upregulated or downregulated which
proteins may need to be prevented from
doing certain activities in order to
prevent disease this means that we have
with the process of genomics and
proteomics faster identification of new
drug targets that is proteins that we
can target with drugs to cure human
diseases in addition to better
understanding of cell processes genomics
and proteomics also give us a better
understanding of human genetics perhaps
the best example of this is that before
the human genome was sequenced
scientists believed that the majority of
the genome coded for proteins and in
fact we now know that that's completely
incorrect less than 2%
of all of our DNA pose for proteins the
other
98.5% codes for non protein sequences
things like introns regulatory sequences
centromeres telomeres transpose xi and
these are things that scientists are now
really getting to dig into what do they
mean for human genetics what do they
mean for cell processes how do they
affect physiology and disease this adds
a whole new layer of complexity to the
human genome there is only really just
beginning to be explored another reason
that genomics and proteomics are
important is because they give us a
better understanding of evolution by
comparing whole genomes comparing
genomes of different species to each
other we can see how closely related
those species are this allows scientists
to build phylogenetic trees and to
determine how certain species are
related to each other
how closely related they are what their
similarities and differences are and
this tells us a great deal about the
evolutionary processes that resulted in
the world as we know it today so that is
the end of our discussion of genomics
and proteomics today here on biology
professor thanks for watching I hope you
learned a lot